hi guys first of all who from the cast
would outsmart ghostface in real life
oh this is a great question
i think
jenna
i think mikey yeah i think so i think
jenna and mikey as a pair yeah would
would be like ghostface would definitely
have a run for yeah yes yeah yeah out of
youtube though like who's picking up the
phone call who's calling 9-1-1 who's
maybe like not turning around who's
going towards the sound like who's
getting caught up here
well we already we decided that uh that
i'm the the idiot the brave idiot let me
just say this i didn't decide this for
her she put this on herself i wasn't
like you're a brave idiot
i decided that i'm the brave idiot that
gets killed very quickly because they
think that they can take on the killer
and dies so i would be that person but i
would sacrifice myself for you that's
that's true
i think you're not giving yourself
enough credit i think you would last
longer than you think you would i i
i think i'm the nerd who kind of knows a
little bit too much about horror movies
in that case i think
i don't think that i think what happens
is i get too caught up in the minutia of
the details and i almost follow the
rules too much and then psych myself out
and and wind up getting murdered i think
that's what happens i i i love you we're
great friends i don't think we're a
great pair and no i don't know
we both died yeah
um jack how would your character huey uh
from the boys stand up to ghost face
oh man i mean he probably would use i
don't even know if i can say it on ut
canada but he would use uh let's just
say he would use the device that he used
in episode two uh on his face he
couldn't get his hands on that he's
screaming and running away probably um
yeah although i don't know huey's seen
some messed up stuff so
maybe maybe like one guy with a knife
isn't that scary to him if he's used to
dealing with like all powerful superman
so maybe he would hold his phone more
than uh more than you think
i love that um melissa i heard that you
became overwhelmed with emotion um
shooting your first scene with nevin
courtney can you just talk us through
like what you were feeling
i mean
i feel like
it was just a moment where i realized
that i was standing in front of
two actresses that i admired
and i've looked up to for so long
and that i'm doing a scene with them
and that i'm
i've been dreaming of a moment like this
for so long and it's and it's happening
and and i was just
it was just like a lot in in the moment
and i was trying to keep my cool and i
was also very nervous and i wanted to be
good
and i wanted to like impress them and i
also didn't want to get fired on the
spot you know like it was it was a lot
of things
so yeah it was overwhelming and and i
was also just so happy in the moment and
i was telling i was like they would yell
cut and i was and there was like nevin
courtney and me in front of them
and i and matt that one other our
directors would walk over to like give
us notes and i'd be like
i'd just be like
and he would like take out his phone and
like snap pictures of us because they
were like
they were like being fans as much as i
was so they were also like super excited
to have these two women there it was the
first day that we shot
with both of them together so
it was surreal so it was a crazy day
yeah i loved it
oh i love that thank you guys for your
time it was great talking to you thank
you
thank you
you